just want to update you on the breaking  news out of vienna  tonight and there's been a shooting  incident we believe  around or in a synagogue in vienna with  shots  exchanged a large police presence on the  ground now now the um  news agency apa has been talking to the  austria  uh interior ministry they say a police  officer has been  shot and seriously injured there are  also reports of one person  being killed though that is yet to be  confirmed  and apa also saying that a suspect has  been arrested  over the shooting in vienna this evening  it happened about  just over an hour or so ago we're  bringing the very latest on that  as we get the details through